Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Sag mal Linus kommst du am Sonntag zur Demo gibt 50 € von der AFD.
Nee das Budget schon erschöpft.
Na dann holen wir uns die Kohle halt von der Antifa.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 255 die 8 Bit sind ausgeschöpft und zwar am.
23.Mai huhu weiß was am 23.Mai ist ne.
Ja der Gründung der Bundesrepublik Deutschland umgeben.
Der hat doch was zu bedeuten.
Das hat jedes Jahr was zu bedeuten aufgeregt auch keine auf.
Aber ist eigentlich völlig egal wann sich so eine Firma gründeten die DEUTSCHLAND GmbH.
Aldi Aldi ist das ja so ein bisschen eine eines der Lieblings Daten im im CCC immer gewesen.
23/5.
Warum ist Jan ja auch alle total bear defense muss mal ehrlich also so eigentlich.
Wir fordern und fördern.
Wie werden.
Die BRD.
Beides.
Ja das könnte man das ganz gut sagen der populäre Musik Konzepte Rektum was durchaus rein rein das ist hier die letzte Sendung vor der großen Sause.
Nächste Woche am Samstag wir haben schon immer mal wieder drauf hingewiesen und viele von euch haben auch schon zugesagt haben da später auch noch ein paar Tipps für euch.
Na wir planen euer Wochenende in Berlin.
Genau und Jörn ansonsten.
Wetter.com es gibt glaube ich noch so drei Tickets gerade noch zu haben also für die Kurzentschlossenen ist unter Umständen auch etwas vor.
Abendkasse wird's nicht geben.
Siamkatze wird nicht geben es wird ja ansonsten.
Also wir wollten doch also der Einlass wird unter Umständen schon früher möglich sein.
Schick mir doch mal eine Mail wir hatten so.
Kommt eine E-Mail von uns wir müssen das noch abklären.
Wir werden den Einlass unter Umständen eine halbe oder gar eine Stunde nach vorne verschieben weil das zeitlich zu eng wird aber da bekommt ihr eine E-Mail von uns wo der wo eine.
Auffrischung der Einlasszeit noch mal angekündigt wird das I.
Dann können sie mich die Gelegenheit nutzen etwas entspannter eure Shirts abzuholen die ihr.
Vorgestellt hat und das ist auch sehr wichtig bitte wenn ihr Shirts vorbestellt hat.
Gehen sie über los und beginnen sich sofort zur zur Shirt Ausgabe und die wird dort dann sein also mit dem Einlassbeginn T-Shirt Ausgabe geht bitte ohne Verzögerung dorthin reiht euch ein.
In die arbeitereinheitsfront und holt eure Shirts ab.
Das hat damit zu tun dass wir wollen möglichst diese die vorgestellten Shirts schon vor Beginn der Veranstaltung weghaben,
weil wir etwas anderes konnte etwas mehr haben davon wir dann in der Pause verkaufen und falls ihr euch nämlich mit der Größe vertan habt haben wir vor Beginn der Sendung noch,
Kontingent darum quasi zu wechseln wenn jetzt achso ich bin gar nicht female es.
Sondern ich bin Male es oder was auch immer dann könnt ihr da noch tauschen und dann in der Pause gibt dann den freien Verkauf und dann wird das alles weg geschnappt.
Genau so ziemlich aus wir Füchse haben an alles gedacht hoffen wir.
Das ist wirklich dieses das ist schon viel viel Detailarbeit.
Muss man sich gar nicht so klar.
Aber damit müssen wir euch ja gar nicht groß belegen sondern wir wollen wie immer eine kompakte Sendung erzeugen und geht dann erstmal zum Feedback über will ich sagen.
Genau Feedback zur Funkzellenabfrage da korrigiert mich andre und sag Linus sagt er,
Autobrandstifter in Berlin sei per Funkzellenabfrage gefangen worden das ist so nicht richtig die Cops haben viele dutzende oder hunderte Funktion abfragen bei Auto Brandon gemacht,
aber überführt wurde er anhand von Videokameras der BVG Beleg anbei.
Also es war eine Kombination aus aus beim wohl nicht so ganz klar wurde was jetzt am Ende alles noch.
Entscheidend ist also es ist richtig entscheiden wo der die Überführung durch die Videokamera der BVG.
Also dadurch sind sie.
Funkzellenabfrage haben massenhaft in Berlin unter anderem deshalb stattgefunden.
Und nicht immer waren sie erfolgreich und das war der auslösende Faktoren davon überhaupt diese gesamte Diskussion angefangen hat über Informationen und so weiter einholen.
Dann haben wir festgestellt in der Diskussion dass es relativ viel in ausgerechnet in Britz.
Funktion abfragen gab dazu kommentiert Mark bzw Andreas.
Und Marx kommentieren Andreas sagt ich kann diesmal helfen die Frage warum in Britz so oft abgefragt wurde,
hängt vermutlich mit der Serie von Brandanschlägen auf Menschen die gegen Rechts kämpfen zusammen Bridge ist leider Zentrum des Nazi Terrors in Berlin,
Mark ergänzt der Vermutung von Andrea steht sich nicht an es gab Anfang 2017 eine Serie von Brandanschlägen kurz darauf hat das Landeskriminalamt die Sonderkommission rechtsextremistische Straftaten in Neukölln,
resin gegründet und auch die Polizeidirektion in Neukölln hat eine spezielle Ermittlungsgruppe daraufhin erneut eingesetzt,
das kann also sehr wahrscheinlich mit der hohen Zahl an Funktion abfragen in Britz zu tun haben.
Hier ein paar Links zum Weiterlesen und recherchieren insbesondere die südlichen Ortsteile also außerhalb,
Brandis S-Bahn Rings von Neukölln sind schon seit Jahren ein Schwerpunkt von Straftaten bei denen eine Verbindung zur echten rechtsextremen Szene vermutet wird.
Fritz ist damals dabei noch mal ein besonderer Schwerpunkt das war mir tatsächlich nicht bekannt und Mark wird hier noch weitere,
Reihe also weitere Beispiele für Anschläge gegen gegen Linke und.
Migranten an und geht so weit zurück wie 2011-2012 also vielen Dank für diese Ergänzungen.
Dann haben wir einen Feedback sehr häufig bekommen nicht zu der letzten Sendung sondern zu der davor wo wir bei der Sonne ja genau der davor wo wir beide.
Gulaschprogrammiernacht zu Gast waren da habe ich mich beklagt das Hawaii pinpoint keine Domain basierte suche hätte das wurde,
x-fach korrigiert in den Kommentaren auf Twitter ich konnte mich gar nicht mehr reden untereinander Simon kommentiert.
Es gibt eine Domain basierte suche bei der muss man dann über einen der üblichen Wege Eigentum an der Domain bestätigen und bekommt alle Adressen protomen das ist dann sowas wie man muss also man kriegt einen Code an postmaster at gesendet,
und dann kriegt man die Meldung für die gesamte Domain.
Das ist sehr praktisch vielen Dank für den Hinweis denn dadurch wird dieser Dienst für mich endlich mal zu.
Nutzen und für die vielen von euch die ihre eigene Domain und Mailserver unterhalten hoffentlich eben auch.
Detlef Albin Pound Servicepaket auch gerade in so Passwort-Manager einge.
All-in-One Passwort ist er glaube ich integriert.
Genau das haben wir es gerade neue Version rausgebracht wurden quasi automatisch gegengecheckt wird mit deinen Account ob das irgendwo auf einer Plattform ist wo bekannte Fälle existieren.
Darf und die haben auch immer so ein Passwort testen aber sie das irgendwie gelöscht dahin schicken und dir dann sagen das Passwort würde ich lieber nicht nehmen das ist in den Standardpasswort Listen und liegst schon vorhanden.
Also das ist tatsächlich eine ganz sinnvolle Sache die Treuhand da vor einigen Jahren eingerichtet hat.
Dann kommentiert,
GKD zur der ganzen pick EPFL Geschichte Linus sagt wenn ihr nicht wisst ob ihr PGP nutzt dann nutzt ihr es auch nicht.
Das stimmt so nicht mehr das projekt autocrypt wir genau,
das erreichen und wird bereits von mehreren Clients unterstützt darunter K9 Mail und Enigma2 es gibt also bestimmt hoffentlich NutzerInnen den das gar nicht bewusst ist nun ja.
Also wer Enigmail nutzlos PGP Enigmail ist das TTT Plugin für Thunderbird und K9 Mail ist ein sehr beliebter E-Mail-Client für.
Für Android und soweit ich da im Bilde bin als ich das letzte Mal beim autocrib Treffen war er ist es auch dort zunächst noch eine,
zu aktivierende Option gewesen das heißt es ist nach wie vor doch sehr sehr unwahrscheinlich dass Menschen.
Dietpi nutzen und das nicht wissen ja kurz zur autocrypt.
Autocrypt ist die Implementierung von opportunistischer Verschlüsselung was heißt opportunistisch.
Opportunistische Verschlüsselung heißt im Prinzip wir machen einfach mal weil wir es können nehmen aber.
In Kauf dass wir hier nicht der reinen Lehre folgen und die bauen also.
Im Prinzip einfach den Key an den zu verschlüsseln sei in jedem E-Mail Header ein.
Wohlwissend dass es sich hierbei um einen unsicheren Kanal für das.
Für das für den Austausch von von public Keys handelt und nutzen dann einfach diesen key.
Und sagen naja wir wissen schon dass das jetzt nicht dem Sicherheitsniveau einer verifizierten Verschlüsselung entspricht und dass das Angriffsszenario.
Machine in the middle hier.
Gegeben sein kann das also eine Person eine Person oder einen ein automatischer Proxy in der Mitte diese Kies diese diese Fingerprint tauschen kann und also einen in der Mitte eine faire und,
wieder Verschlüsselung durchführen kann das heißt dieses ganze Verfahren bietet keinen Schutz gegen aktive Angriffe.
Wenn aber dann einmal die Nachricht verschlüsselt verschicken wurde dann ist sie eben auch nur verschlüsselt auf dem Transportweg das heißt ein Angriff muss aktiv und in die Zukunft gerichtet sein.
Mit anderen Worten wir schützen gegen das Risiko Szenario das retrograd verschlüsselt unverschlüsselte E-Mails auf den.
Berechnen gefunden wurden gefunden gefunden werden gleichzeitig sagen sie wenn es einen Maschinen mittelangriff gibt dann schützbar autocrypt nicht aber.
Nicht autocrypt hätte auch nicht geschützt ja also sagen einfach und das ist denke ich auch eine Insel eine sinnvolle angehensweise zu sagen wenn wir doch verschlüsseln können warum machen wir es nicht einfach erstmal weil es hat ja nichts.
Und das ist also eine Initiative die jetzt auch schon seit ein paar Jahren irgendwie.
In der Diskussion hat jetzt den ein oder anderen kleinen der es unterstützt natürlich wie alle Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung Mechanismen.
Probleme dass man es eben den Leute dafür die Leute das nicht ohne ihre Kenntnis tun können dass man trotzdem das Problem mit der Schlüssel Aufbewahrung und so weiter hat aber insgesamt etwas das zu begrüßen ist.
Wenngleich sehen das Lied.
Genannten Probleme auch auf weiß das auch hier die Schwierigkeit ist wie man das in der Breite ausgeräumt bekommt.
Wenn es Enigmail unterstützt schöne gut wenn es K9 Mail unterstützt schoenundgut spannend wäre wenn Gmail und Thunderbird und web.de ist unterstützen.
Darauf kann man dann eben noch hoffen.
Das ist irgendwie eine Chance dass es irgendwann noch mal sowas wie let's encrypt aber für Essen gibt was ja nun wirklich auf jedem Telefon läuft.
Naja Essen sitzen ist es ja zu sagen dass es mal im Moment hat der noch schlechtere.
Unter Berücksichtigung Berücksichtigung der E-Feld Angriffe hat erstmal noch sehr viel schlechter abgeschnitten als PDP.
Also nicht erstmal in die Verschlüsselung sollen die Implementierung video mit HTML umgegangen wird das dann sicherlich auch etwas was hoffentlich bald durch Softwareupdate behoben wird.
Ich weiß das oder ich meine als du das letzte Mal mit den.
Let's encrypt Leuten gesprochen habe dass sie es meinem Zertifikate nachwievor irgendwo auf ihre Roadmap haben und das auch mal tun wollen.
Das Eschental.
Das wäre schon toll,
aber bis dahin müssten auch erstmal leider diese ganzen ebay Sachen g****** werden und bisher z.b. auch feststellen ich kann bei Apple Mail und bei iOS nicht feststellen dass sie da irgendwie sich bewegt hätten,
ich habe auch in der in den vergangenen Tagen noch mal ein bisschen Austausch gehabt mit den Forschern zu I fail.
Die sich da ein bisschen zu geäußert haben sagt sie.
So hallo wir mit dem besten Wissen und Gewissen gehandelt wir haben eine Perspektive wir haben disclosure Zeiten gehabt wir haben gesagt dass ich Sachen das Sachen g****** werden müssen es ist nicht passiert so werden im Prinzip,
responsible disclosure process gemacht wie jeder andere,
wie die im anderen Fall auch und sehen uns nun massiver Kritik ausgesetzt wo ich noch mal sagen muss also wir haben in der letzten Sendung nicht.
Die Issel Forscher kritisiert ganz im Gegenteil ich habe ja gerade relativ ausführlich gesagt sondern eben einige der Reaktion die hiervon von Medien gezeigt wurden.
Und der IFF und anderen.
Bfft also auch einen Kommentar zugesagt OTH TIFF hat doch nur.
Alle haben immer nur die Besten Intention aber wann hat die EF erstmal die Aktivierungs und Installationsanleitung in in verschiedenen für alle Betriebssysteme herausgebracht ja,
bei einem Angriff der eben nunmal tatsächlich nicht in der Breite in diesem Ausmaß stattfinden wird aber das haben wir letzte Sendung gesprochen,
alles ist alles was irgendwie zu Verschlüsselung führt ist gut und alles was diese Verschlüsselungs Implementierungen verbessert ist gut und damit ist auch die Forschung dieses Veltins,
gut und alles andere ist Wasser unter der Brücke und ein paar verletzte Egos und Zankereien.
Aber jetzt kommen eigentlich die Kurzmeldungen für den Thema auch direkt noch mit dazu nehmen.
Ja dann nehmen wir das noch kurz mit auf das Thema ging natürlich weiter also in der letzten Woche haben wir ja gesagt okay ist gab diese E-Mail Angriff ich habe jetzt schon gesagt bei Apple warte ich irgendwie darauf dass die mal sagen wir haben uns der Sache angenommen.
Währenddessen zeigte hanno Böck dann neue UCLA basierte Angriffe die sich auch in den neuen Versionen niederschlagen von.
Von.
Das gab quasi die neue Enigmail Version wo dann irgendwie dran stand jetzt ohne E-Mail und hanno Böck der.
In der ja ich würde sagen in der kryptoszene schon bekannt ist für seinen Sachverstand und bei Golem schreibt primär.
Hat sich dann der Sache noch mal angenommen hatten neue Methoden gefunden die Siri fällt Sachen in einer also die quasi Auszug.
Nutzen indem er komplexere HTML-Elemente baut das hat er dann natürlich gemeldet es gibt also jetzt eine neue Enigmail Variante diesmal wahrscheinlich tatsächlich wirklich ohne e fail.
WhatsApp Signal der hat also der Ivan.
Ivan Barrera Oro nachgelegt ja der hat ja auch sein diese ml injection Schwachstelle im Desktop-Client gezeigt und hat jetzt eine neue eine neue Variante auch der hat wieder diesen.
Eine neue cvetinovic mit einer neuen Schwachstelle in in in Sydney.
Seid ja so das Fest ist steht eins zu eins.
Und das wird immer so bleiben das wird so bleiben dass das Schwachstellen gefunden werden und daneben behoben werden müssen.
Ja weil auch einfach manchmal sind auch solche Sachen man in gewisser Hinsicht finde ich das auch ganz.
Gut dass das jetzt hier auf einmal so viel Thermik drumherum ist weil es zeigt natürlich im Vergleich zu früher ein doch erheblich gestiegen das Interesse an dem Thema als solchen.
Ja also, diesen alten Mythos gerade mit OpenSource ja.
1000000 icebugs erstelle oder anders ausgedrückt werden nur genug Leute draufschauen dann dann wäre noch alle Bugs gefunden bei bestimmten Technologien bestimmte Anwendung,
scheiterte das einfach immer auch allein schon daran dass da einfach nicht genug Leute drauf schauten uns nicht genug Leute für wichtig erachtet haben und Crypto hat nun seit Snowden im Norm zugenommen finde ich,
hat gesehen was letzten Crypt bewegt hat also in dem Moment.
Wo auch für Sommer mal solide gute technische Lösungen daher kommen dann können die eben auch durchaus zum Erfolg führen meine wer muss noch verwirrt vor wenigen Jahren.
Da war das normal dass Facebook über HTTP ausgeliefert wird kann man sich heute überhaupt nicht mehr vorstellen und.
Ich kann überhaupt nicht mehr vorstellen Facebook auch noch ausgeliefert wird aber ist ein anderes Thema.
Ja gut aber sogar das ja also das ist das haarsträubende also ich weiß aber ich glaube auf der ersten.
Publica habe ich mir irgendwie auch den Spaß gemacht habe irgendwie mein Passwort Scanner laufen zu lassen und so weiter.
Sehr großes Gezanke.
Ich habe großes großes getankt und aufregend und überhaupt und wie ich das nur könnte und so weiter.
Damit dies nicht noch weit gekommen damals ne.
So ich meine jetzt auch nicht groß Experten mäßig rangegangen aber es war halt einfach alles lactana blockt alle Blogger Deutschland waren Verein an einem Ort und man konnte halt mal problemlos auch auf alle Blogs Deutschland an,
Zugriff erlangen administrativen so habe ich natürlich nicht getan.
Aber das hat.
Wichtig ist es ist gut dass die Leute draufschauen.
Immer wenn eine Schwachstelle gefunden und publiziert wird heißt das dass sie kurz oder mittelfristig weg ist und.
Das ist gut für uns alle nicht so gut ist das wenn dann daraus so.
Zeig mal so Zankereien und sowas entstehen und gerade in dieser Eifel Geschichte gab es dann irgendwie Matthew green der in der,
in der SZ dann zitiert wurde ja das ist ein weiterer Nagel zum Sarg von diesem aus allen Löchern stinkenden PGP.
Sorry so muss man halt so geht man nicht miteinander um ne also das ist denke ich das war einfach ein bisschen zu viel des Guten so der hat natürlich seine Argumente.
Ja aber da muss man dann muss man sich auch nicht wundern dass die Menschen die halt hier Pipi seit mitunter Jahrzehnten pflegen.
Und die eine ganze Menge mehr Briten in der Zeit angehäuft haben als jetzt irgendwie moxxi's Team um Signal in den letzten vier Jahren ja.
Da muss man nicht da muss man nicht zu solchen Worten greifen,
ja das ist unnötig in einem solchen Fall die Debatte so an zu schwitzen es sei denn man kann einen konkreten.
Vorwurf gegen andere im Rahmen des incident Handling machen also die Sache ist ja einfach an in verschiedenen Stellen.
Unnötig entgleist und das war zu bedauern ja würde ich jetzt mal allgemein für diese Michelle sagen insgesamt ist es,
immer gut wenn.
Schwachstellen gefunden und in diesem Rahmen beseitigt werden und immer schade wenn im Prinzip auf beiden Seiten die Guten sind einerseits hier die,
Forscher die die Schwachstellen entdeckt haben und andererseits die Entwickler,
die diese Software seit vielen Jahren pflegen und bereitstellen und die sich dann irgendwie in den Köpfen haben und gegenseitig.
Ib beschimpfen das ist schade wenn sowas entgleist und umso bevor ich da sind wir wenn wir hier als unbeteiligte Dritte beiden können nein mach mal hier gerade nicht.
Immer nur die Lügenpresse.
So dann haben wir noch.
Doch genug zum Waschen da.
Anonymes Feedback vom Hack und Back und zwar aber der letzten Sendung ja schon,
Sendung mit dem Titel Hack und Back und hatten in der letzten Sendung noch mal darüber gesprochen das Maßen ja jetzt langsam sich in diese Richtung Vorwerk dass er eben sein dass er auch HAK und Buck haben möchte.
Also Herr Maaßen der Chef vom Verfassungsschutz.
Und wir hatten auch darüber gesprochen dass.
Pack und Pack eben nur geht wenn man das ordentlich vorbereitet man könnte sagen wie sagt man dass ein ordentlicher Hefeteig muss eben 24 Stunden gehen.
Und deswegen kann man nicht spontan mal eben Hefeteig machen und so kann man sich das mit dem Haken auch vorstellen.
Und dazu haben wir eben davor gewarnt dass ihr dass er jetzt sehr langsam in diese Richtung geht das er sagt wir möchten.
Präventiv Pflege vorbereiten und alle wollen uns hacken wenn wir eine kleine E-Mail bekommen ich arbeite bei einem Energieversorger und da wurde heute der Verfassungsschutz höchst persönlich vorstellig.
Darf ich von einem befreundeten Geheimdienst bzw Sicherheitsunternehmen darauf hingewiesen wurden dass unser Unternehmen wohl namentlich als Ziel genannt wurde wie immer kam nichts genaues dabei herum außer dass es wohl der Russe.
Sein soll es wurden keine genauen Quellen der Info oder auch nur Ziele der Angriffe genannt.
Bleibt also nur die Frage wie viele andere Energieunternehmen dieselbe Art von Besuch erhalten haben, also im Prinzip natürlich davon ausgehen dass es alle waren und ja also.
Der Verfassungsschutz tourt gerade und wir können also uns damit darauf einrichten dass wir wahrscheinlich noch in dieser Legislaturperiode in Zweifelsfall vom heimathorst einen.
Einen Gesetzesvorschlag irgendwo untergejubelt bekommen wo ist wo ist dann um ausgeprägte Offensive Fähigkeiten der deutschen Geheimdienste gehen wird.
Und da darf man sich war nicht jetzt schon vor eben nicht davon ablenken lassen dass da immer nur defensiv stehen wird ja.
Auch wenn es jetzt in diesem Fall vermutlich in einem defensiven Kontext gemeint war also.
Naja aber sie dass der Punkt ist Haag und Park geht nicht rein defensiv.
Du wirst nicht spontan sagen können jetzt schnell an die Tastatur Männer sondern du wirst sagen müssen infiltriert schonmal und wenn wir dann irgendwann mal müssen dann richten wir auch dann dann quasi dann haben wir die integritätsverletzungen der Systeme um sie auszuweiten,
auf was weiß ich eine auf eine Sabotage oder eine Spionage was auch immer in diesem Fall notwendig ist.
Das geht aber nicht.
Spontan das heißt sie wollen jetzt schon infiltrieren um vorzubereiten und das ist offensiv und nicht defensiv und sowie die sich kontrollieren lassen.
Die Erfahrung die wir bisher mit diesen Institutionen gemacht haben wissen wir dass sie auch dieses Recht erstens sehr vage nur formuliert haben.
Wollen werden in ihrem Gesetzentwurf und den 720 selber schreiben und das ist dann größtmöglich intergros großzügig möglich interpretieren werden und dann demnächst überall drin hängen.
So leuchtet immer.
Markiert meine Worte.
Ja überall mit dabei auf allen Partys ist jetzt auch Zuckerberg Zuckerberg weil.
Lauf mal Feedback bekommen warum spricht ihr den Deutsch aus.
Naja ist halt deutscher Name irgendwo ne.
Also russisch auszusprechen finde ich jetzt auch übertrieben.
Man könnte auch Zuckerberg sagen hackerberg hackerberg.
Sag kaburga werkstättenordnung.
Ja aber er ist schon ist schon ein bisschen auch in mountain of Sack.
Du ich würde also aus seiner Perspektive ist das ja wohl gestern äußerst gut gelaufen.
Ja ja deswegen sagt das ja auch so total.
Wasser passiert also er stellte sich freiwillig.
Den Fragen des EU Parlamentes.
Hat aber so ein Teil der Bedingungen diktiert und dazu gehörte es gibt keine Frage Antwort Ping Pong sondern eher zu Beginn werden die Fragen gesammelt und dann nimmt er dazu Stellung.
Also wer sich auf sowas einlässt.
Wer sich auf sowas einlässt ja das ist natürlich und das war dann auch scheint mir eines der großen Verhängnis dieser gesamten Veranstaltung die darin bestand das 12 Abgeordnete ihn getroffen haben.
Es gab einen Livestream der ganzen Geschichte.
Und vielleicht ist kleiner ich habe den nicht gesehen ich war in der Deutschen Bahn und in der Deutschen Bahn gibt kein Internet.
War nicht so einfach irgendwie auf dieser irgendwer lament Seite schrie die webseite nach irgendeinem Plugin was ich hier nicht weiter recherchiert habe was es war.
Live.
Der das gab's dann noch dazu.
Parlament macht heute ein Facebook live mit Sack und Pack seid alle mit dabei klickt jetzt okay surf Abgeordnete Livestream.
Und dann gibt's ja dann geht das Los mit zu den Button ja vor der Tür wartet natürlich der Presse Pulk auf das Eintreffen,
Zuckerbergs und dann kommt da also da rein und da und da stehen dann irgendein paar Leute die in in Empfang nehmen der Parlamentspräsident,
Kajaani sprich mal gegenläufig außen.
Sowie auch.
Antonio Tajani ist vaiana hat gesagt ich würde es keinen Staatschef den nehme ich nicht eben empfangen kann gefährlich,
dann kommen wir hinkommen soll ja mir ein Zimmer genannt und dann ja das ist Diplomatie nadezda dass man den eben dass der nicht,
Bimini unten Empfang genommen wird sondern dass der da antreten muss wie jeder andere auch machen natürlich die ganzen.
Mach die Presse nicht mit und steht natürlich trotzdem unten und schieß die Bilder so dann kommt er kommt er da hoch.
Musste dich erstmal 1000 selfies noch mit irgendwelchen Hero Mitarbeiter an.
Die ich heiße selfies waren aber wie dem auch sei also er kommt da an und jetzt war der Termin auf 90 Minuten terminiert.
So und was passiert und so 12 Uhr Abgeordneten stehen da.
Und müssen weil es ja kein Ping Pong gibt Ihre Fragen erst einmal quasi vortragen.
Um dann irgendwann am Ende dem Herrn Zuckerberg die Gelegenheit zu geben der dann die Fragen gesammelt hat darauf zu antworten.
Und sie haben mitunter relativ strenge Fragen die Sie um sie zu unterstreichen.
Um einige Koreferat anreichern sodass am Ende ca eine Stunde diese parlamentaria reden.
Nach und nach ihre Fragen vortragen und vielleicht auch mal eine eine oder andere politische Forderung einstreuen wie Facebook muss zerschlagen werden und schwuppdiwupp ist eine Stunde von den 90 Minuten rum und er gut Herr Zuckerberg hat leider.
Nur noch 25 minuten zu diesen Fragen Stellung zu nehmen,
gibt in dieser Stellungnahme im Prinzip die gleichen Antworten dir den US-Kongress schon mal gegeben hat und will dann am Ende.
Das Ding selber beenden sat also ja also für die Ärzte auch niemanden zu viel Zeit stehen und die,
jetzt langsam rum woraufhin Jan Philipp Albrecht irgendwie sogar noch mal protestiert und sagt bleiben Sie hier und dann die anderen.
Und dann stellen sie fest ja die Fragen die wir jetzt hier in in 60 Minuten gestellt haben die hat ja gar nicht alle beantwortet.
Super super.
The big surprise und er sagt eine Visionär okay dann,
den Rest machen wir schriftlich kein Thema tschau ja,
jetzt muss er sich überlegen was bedeutete diese ganze was sollte diese Veranstaltung Überwachungsverein was bedeutete diese Veranstaltung für den guten Herrn,
Zuckerberg der hatte im Prinzip zwei Aufgaben erstens.
Sich nicht in der Form zu blamieren oder spezifische Situationen nehmen Admin Pflegesituationen zugeben wie es im Kongress der Fall war wo es ja mehrere,
Teile dieser viele Stunden dauernden Anhörung da gibt.
Sei es von seinem Sprechzettel der Foto von seinem Sprechzettel bestimmte komische Situation in der in den er gegrinst hat oder sonstiges ja.
Das hat er größtenteils durch dieses Verbotes pink.
Einfach unterbunden weil den dann niemand mehr unter ins Wort fallen konnte keine Nachfragen kommen konnten und er eben einfach auch unangenehme Fragen ignorieren konnte was er getan hat zweite Aufgabe sollte.
Für ihn war natürlich eines der Primärziele die dort anwesenden Leute davon zu überzeugen dass Facebook an der Sache dran ist.
Sich darum kümmert und keine Regulierung notwendig ist von deren Seite das ist natürlich und Zweifelsfall schief gegangen.
Wenn er dort die wenn er dort nur 25 Minuten Redezeit hat und die am Ende eine schriftliche Beantwortung vereinbaren muss und.
Also das gleiche wie selbständig schon beenden wollte das wird er die Leute nicht wirklich überzeugt haben da wird ja eher ein relativ knatschige.
Delegation von Abgeordneten hinterlassen haben die jetzt im Zweifelsfall nicht befriedet sind unter anderem weil sie sich da muss man einfach mal sagen blamiert haben.
Währenddessen ließen am gleichen Tag noch oder in den gleichen Zeitraum wieder einseitige Anzeigen in den großen deutschen Tageszeitungen pro dsgvo.
Laut.fm dsgvo facebook wird noch besser gut gut gut.
Und jetzt frage ich mich soll man sowas überhaupt machen solche Anhörung was bringt das ja diese ganze Sache im US-Kongress war eigentlich.
Ähnlich Leben dass er dann so ein paar,
Pinkernell also klar dann wird er mal irgendwie zurechtgewiesen von dem einen Senator oder von irgendjemand anders dann blamiert sich der eine oder andere der deine Anhörung macht dann kriegt er mal hier kurz einen von Lars von Jan Philipp Albrecht so so aber das war eine brot und Spiele.
Ja das interessiert doch also.
Bitte vergessen nicht zu vergessen den verstörten Rechtsausleger der sich noch in seiner Opferrolle noch mal präsentieren möchte den USA fast Tattoos der verrückte texaner und in Europa natürlich.
Vettel Ferrari halt beklagt hat das ja seitdem sich die Algorithmen geändert haben ja viel weniger von ihrem rechten kramfedertasche leiden.
Seitdem sie diese Kenntnisse vertiefen.
Können wir treffen uns nicht mehr ordentlich durch ja okay alles klar danke vielleicht scheint doch das andere anderen zugreifen immerhin.
Naja also,
wer am Ende hatte er hat sich entschuldigt er hat gesagt ja ok da müssen wir leider sind wir unser Verantwortung nicht gerecht geworden das machen wir jetzt wir werden jetzt wir müssen aber auch sagen werden positive Einflüsse z.b. wir können Leuten nach Terroranschlägen bitte ein dass sie in Sicherheit sind also,
nee Leute wir können anderen Leuten mitteilen also es ist ja dieses wenn du fällst wenn irgendwie in deiner Nähe was war weil Facebook ja weiß dass du da kannst ja dann irgendwie einchecken dass es dass es dir gut geht ne.
Ja nee dann ist gut also dafür können wir ruhig so irgendwie so Cambridge analytica hätten wir ruhig sein,
Abend können dafür dass er jetzt über Facebook sagen können dass sein Sicherheit sind nach dem BMW in der Nähe von einem Unglück fahren,
ansonsten sagt er aber,
natürlich Jobs Jobs Jobs NRW bis Ende des Jahres 20 000 Personen im Sicherheitsteam haben und auch in Europa,
wir mal wieder am Ende des Jahres zehntausend Menschen beschäftigen also 3000 mehr als gegenwärtig da hat der schon relativ gut verstanden die Politik funktioniert.
Wenn man das sagt so übrigens.
Dank der weitgehenden regulierungs losigkeit sind wir in der Lage dreitausend Menschen hier anzustellen da kriegt er auch ein Stück vom Kuchen ab der Softball.
Das sind natürlich dass diese 3000 die wird sehr schnell wieder zur Sprache kommen sollte nun irgendjemand in Richtung.
Zerschlagung Regulierung oder sonstigen von face,
argumentieren was also im weitesten als Markt Hemmnis also als Beeinträchtigung des ungewöhnlichen Geschäftsmodells interpretiert werden könnte dann wären wir diese Zahl sehr schnell wiedersehen.
Ganz zu arbeiten so arbeitet man eben in der Branche den in jeder Branche.
Mama geht das eigentlich nicht.
3000 Leute anstellen.
Wir können ja mal ein paar Arbeitsplatz in Aussicht stellen.
Womit denn.
Ja weiß nicht warum aber das muss ja auch nicht mal passieren kann das ja erstmal überhaupt.
Die Frage ist wen hast du dich dieser Sache ja also das EU-Parlament hat ja die Wanne eigentlich stolz dass der dass sie den zusichert zitieren konnten und Versandbedingungen,
können schon keine Gesetze formulieren so ungefähr aber sind wichtig genug dass dass dass der Zuckerberg kommt am Ende setzte sich der Soli Nesseln und 1 Handynetz selber machen da halt lassen sich halt die Butter vom Brot nehmen.
Ja gut Mann ist die Frage ob ihr zu sehr viel bei herausgekommen wäre wenn jetzt der Frage Modus sehr viel anders gewesen wäre am Ende wäre auch in der Lage gewesen die Fragen direkt ab zu tun also meine Erwartungshaltung war,
ohnehin nicht sonderlich groß und von daher.
Keine Ahnung was hier jetzt so im,
Parlament die Erwartungshaltung dagewesen ist vielleicht hat man tatsächlich geglaubt man könnte jetzt eine billige Alternative zu dieser Senat Befragung USA bieten das sicherlich dann nicht gelungen.
Aber am Ende scheint.
Das Bedrohungsszenario der EU auch noch nicht so groß zu sein wenn das so ausgehen kann also dieses ganze zerschlagen von Facebook.
UPS ein bisschen meine Zweifel dass das wirklich durchsetzungsfähig sein wird in Europa.
Unter was könnte denn Facebook sozusagen groß Angst machen.
Ganz genau dass das ist also ein Verbot des Geschäftsmodells.
Na gut aber auf Basis von welcher.
Also finde zerschlag.
Argumentation.
Finde Zerschlagung brauchst du ja quasi Geschäftsbereiche in die Dusche schlägst.
Kannst jetzt irgendwie Telekommunikationskonzern irgendwie geographisch zerschlagen oder du kannst.
Den im Netzbetrieb und Servicebetrieb zerschlagen aber in was willst du Facebook zerschlagen in WhatsApp und Messenger und Facebook.
Das sehr sehr sehr sehr schwierig da überhaupt irgendwo einen zweiten Hebel anzulegen und gewisser Hinsicht hat er die aktuelle Gesetzgebung Facebook auch noch eher in die Karten gespielt also die ganze,
Reaktion auf api-zugriff führt ja nur dazu dass Facebook sagte.
Mangel an Einsicht.
Mama hat den Laden dicht bleibt alles bei uns kriegt keiner mehr was hat mehr glaube ich schon diskutiert ist damals noch.
Auf dieser App Welle geschwommen sind und dachten das wäre sozusagen gutes Geschäftsmodell aber mittlerweile,
facebook hat genug Hebel über die sie eben die Leute auf ihrer Plattform ziehen Ops jetzt hier Katastrophen sicherheitsmeldung.
Für einzelne sind oder eben generell dieses geh dahin wo alle anderen sind.
Und von daher machen sie da gerne auch die Tür zu und lassen da überhaupt gar keinen Markt zu das stört die halt überhaupt nicht weil mittlerweile sind sie.
Die größten und wenns halt auch auf absehbare Zeit bleiben zumindest in der westlichen Hemisphäre zu global gesehen ist normal eine andere Geschichte aber ich glaube über die Situation in Asien kann man relativ wenig sagen.
Was war das nicht wissen oder wissen nur ansatzweise wissen oder meinen zu wissen.
Wechat.
Genau aber wir werden uns dem Thema auch demnächst mal annehmen.
So werden wir es tun.
Gut also war nicht viel zu erwarten ist auch nicht viel passiert vielleicht fragen wir einfach Jan Philipp Albrecht noch mal bei denen am Samstag bei uns haben.
So dann gibt es eine gute Nachricht versuchen wir ja alle 5 Sendung versuchen wir eine gute Nachricht.
Der BND beendet die illegale Datenverarbeitung im Veras im Verkehrsanalyse System,
wir hatten dieses Thema immer wieder behandelt denn 2015 hatte.
Reporter ohne Grenzen eine Klage eingereicht weil.
Journalistinnen und Journalisten immer wieder in diesem metadatenanalyse.
Des BND geraten also diese bei diesem System handelt es sich darum dass die Metadaten von Telefongesprächen analysieren um so quasi Netze.
Soziale Netze zu erkennen und zu sehen wer kommuniziert mit wem und dann sagen sie natürlich ja das bringt unsere Quellen in Gefahr.
Und behindert uns bei der arbeit wenn wir.
Unseren internationalen Quellen gegenüber nicht zusichern können dass der deutsche Bundesnachrichtendienst Sie bei der Kommunikation mit uns nicht unter Umständen doch erfasst und da wurde dann im Dezember 2017,
Urteil dass der BND keine Rechtsgrundlage für den Betrieb von Veras hat und dass er ist daher.
In Zukunft unterlassen muss die Daten von Reporter ohne Grenzen darin zu verarbeiten und das schöne daran ist dass dadurch das Reporter ohne Grenzen das,
quasi diesen Einspruch einmal quasi für sich selber durchgesetzt hat hatte den Waden und prinzipiell für alle Menschen zu erheben,
möglich diesen zu erheben und deswegen wurde am bei der Republica anfangen mal von Christian Meyer und Christoph Elzer ein Online-Tool vorgestellt.
Bei dem man sich auf das Leipziger Urteil berufen konnte den bitte nicht durchleuchten BND Generator.
Roman also quasi kurz seine Daten eingetragen hat und dann eine.
Bin in kurzer Zeit mehrere tausend derartige Anfragen beim BND eingingen,
und jetzt hat der BMW BMW in Anbetracht dieser über 2000 Anträge kapituliert und hat allgemein erklärt dass er,
Veras in der bekannten Form nicht mehr weiter betreibt das ist ein Erfolg.
Natürlich ist das ein Etappensieg denn den bmdw sicherlich relativ bald was neues einfallen aber.
Zunächst einmal ist also dieses vera's nun dank dem langen Atem von Reporter ohne Grenzen.
Erstmal deaktiviert und alles was es gebraucht hat ist zwei Jahre 60 und ein Online-Tool das naja immerhin.
Männer.
Das ist das ist schön so so wird dieser so werden diese Kämpfe geführt und das ist.
Wenn man sich überlegt wie viele Personen Stunden in dem Scheiß jetzt drin stecken.
Ist das natürlich da kann man mal sehen wie viel Arbeit so etwas macht und warum diese Institution eben Spenden brauchen und Mitglieder brauchen bei dieser Organisation um so etwas.
Zu tun.
Herzlichen Dank an Reporter ohne Grenzen und herzlichen Glückwunsch und den Spendenlink haben wir bei uns in den Ton aus.
Und die schön ist auch immer wieder zu sehen ist wie diese.
Pfiffigen puls dieser vergleichsweise einfachen und manchmal auch nicht ganz einfachen Softwarelösungen auch in der Lage sind politische Prozesse zu befördern insofern.
Wer von euch.
Coding skills hat und irgendwie schon lange mal wieder auf so ein kratz Moment gewartet hat wo man mal bisschen was,
formieren sollte das ist sicherlich so einen Bereich wo man seine Energie ganz gut umsetzen kann.
Iris hatte ich auch klein im Nachhinein leuchtet das natürlich eine aber der BND war natürlich auch nicht vorbereitet der Bär in die ist ja jetzt nicht irgendwie so eine der hat ja keine Kundenhotline.
So nah und damit ist natürlich klar wenn du einer solchen Organisation.
2007 schickst und auf und Erfüllung verlangst ja dass der Sie Ihre Systeme so bauen müssen dass sie bestimmte Daten nicht mehr erfassen dann hast du.
Die vor einem vor eine unmögliche Herausforderung gestellt und deswegen haben die hier kapitulieren müssen retrospektiv kann man sowas immer relativ einfach erklären aber es natürlich sehr.
Sehr schöne rechtlich wären sie gezwungen gewesen das zu tun und sie hätten diese Anträge jetzt auch noch prüfen müssen und damit haben sie es jetzt irgendwie erstmal sein lassen.
Vorsichtig ich gehe nicht davon aus dass sie dauerhaft noch in 10 Jahren sagen werden ja nie,
weil wir damals die 2000 anfangen von vom Reporter ohne Grenzen Generator bekommen haben werden wir das nie wieder uns in diesem Bereich der aus dem Ausland Überwachung.
Vorwagen aber so ist dass das Bohren von dicken Brettern mit dünnen Rohren.
Ich brauche Geduld und Spucke.
Ja wenig Geduld hat die CSU gezeigt.
Und hat dann einfach mal beschlossen was sich schon abgezeichnet hat nehme ich das neue tolle polizeiaufgabengesetz der neue Stern,
Legislatur Himmel der du bist ein Eindruck macht als ob er als nächstes abgeschossen gehört.
Haben wir ja hier besprochen das ist das neue umstrittene Gesetz was zu zahlreichen neue Mittel rechtfertigt im Polizeieinsatz.
Obwohl es die dicke fette dem oder geben daB und,
generell gerade aus rechtskundigen Bereichen sehr viel Widerstand dazu kam hat die CSU einfach nicht interessiert obwohl,
das auch keine nennenswerten Steigerung der Kriminalitätsraten gibt mussten einfach mal neue Maßnahmen beschlossen werden weil.
Der Wahlen bald wieder in Bayern und muss ja was tun.
Grüne und SPD haben aber auf jeden Fall Verfassungsklagen angekündigt so auch die BFF ob das ein koordinierter koordinierte Anstrengung wird weiß ich nicht so ganz genau.
Lässt sich.
Eigentlich nur hoffen weil es jetzt nicht unbedingt von Vorteil ist dass man möglichst vielen Tagen kommt das muss halt vor allem eine geben die Verfassungsgericht auch in ihrer Formulierung und Ausrichtung überzeugt.
Und das ist wahrscheinlich so das was so als naechsten zu erwarten ist.
Ist ausgegangen 89 zu 67 Stimmen bei 2 Enthaltungen wurde das Ganze im Bayerischen Landtag durchgesetzt und ich weiß gar nicht wann geht das geht das sofort oder.
Nee das wird also die haben ja ich weiß nicht genau wann das Inkrafttreten ist das ist ja üblicherweise.
Bild veröffentlicht ist.
Wenn es veröffentlicht ist und dann gibt's teilweise sehr fleißig tatsächlich nicht niemals unmittelbar es ist aber entschieden das heißt es wird jetzt nicht mehr lange dauern.
Mura naja,
also es gibt auf jeden Fall eine Initiative der Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte GFF wie schon erwähnt und die,
haben einen sprechendes Crowdfunding für diese Geschichte gestartet um die Mittel zu haben um diese Verfassungsklage dann auch rund zu machen und zum Erfolg zu bringen.
Ich denke mal hier gibt's gute Chancen.
Na und es ist halt auch besonders wichtig weil wir ja gerade einen Innenminister haben der aus Bayern kommt.
Der sicherlich sehr genau darüber im Bilde ist was da los ist und ja auch schon zu gegebenen Anlässen hat verlauten lassen.
Dass er das so großartig findet was Bayern da wieder getan hat dass er das als Vorbild für die Bundesrepublik sieht.
Und da können wir also davon ausgehen dass wir einen sehr ähnlichen.
Eine sehr ähnliche Herangehensweise eine sehr ähnliche Initiative auch auf Bundesebene im Rahmen dieser Legislaturperiode noch sehen werden.
Blau.
So dann gab es noch eine andere Abstimmung die war nicht ganz so doof wenn auch vielleicht nicht so Folgen wirksam wie man sich das gerne wünschen würde in den USA,
steht ja seit längerem wieder ein Rollback an darüber berichtet die SEC die Vettel Vettel.
Communications.
Communications Commission genau.
Ferrari communications.
Die FCC Radio mit so einem.
Trump Freund besetzt wurde in der Führung und dann halten wir noch mit knapper Mehrheit erstmal intern durchgesetzt hat dass man doch gerne diesen ist Neutralität wieder loswerden will die Obama 2015 mit Mühe durchgesetzt hat,
und man möchte das also ganz gerne wieder rückgängig machen damit man halt wieder von großen Telcos,
ordentlich betrogen werden kann weil ich mal um einen.
Ordnungsgemäßen Internetzugang naja auf jeden Fall musste das ganze diese Regeln konnte sie FCC jetzt nicht einfach so durchsetzen sonst Bedarf quasi einer.
Bestätigung auf.
Parlamentarischer Ebene da gibt's ja in den USA gleich zwei nehme ich den Senat also das ist ja der Teil der quasi bisschen so.
Städtevergleich aber hat er so Bundesrat Epil aber mehr macht also da sind halt Vertreter aus den einzelnen US Staaten,
und dann gibt's noch das Haus was ist mir zu unserem Bundestag hält der Senat wiederum,
hatte jetzt das ganze zur Abstimmung und siehe da mit einer Entscheidung von 52 zu 47 Stimmen.
Sind diese neuen Regeln abgewählt worden.
Kurzum die Form die Formalitäten dahinter noch mal zu verdeutlichen das ist nicht zustimmungspflichtig das Gesetz sondern unter dem congressional Review act.
Darf der Gesetzgeber diesen STC Beschluss aufheben und.
Ähnliche Beschlüsse für die Zukunft verbieten das heißt die FCC kann hier erstmal agieren wie sie möchte und das haben sie ja getan mit den drei zu zwei Votum gegen Netzneutralität welches am 11. Juni.
Inkrafttreten soll und nun kann der Kongress also.
Senat und House of Representatives.
Das entweder einfach laufen lassen oder aktiv etwas dagegen tun und das ist jetzt im Senat geschehen wo die Senatoren nun müsste.
99 Nordhorn geben wenn ich mich nicht täusche.
Nissen 130.
Ok aber einer ist gerade krank ne.
Einer ist also mindestens einer ist krank der mercaden aber der ist eh nicht mehr so richtig auf Trump Seite keine Ahnung wer.
3 haben sich enthalten nee also genau dann aber okay lassen wir das wie viel ist genau sind unendlich jetzt hat also der Senat.
Hat gesagt okay wir möchten einem motion eine Gegenstimme verabschieden und das haben sie nun 52 zu 47 getan das ist also eine Resolution die sagt hier diese FCC.
Das da sind wir dagegen dass sie das tun das verbieten wir denen.
Und diese Resolution wird nun in das House of Representatives gehen.
Ja also.
Die zweite Kammer oder ist das die erste, ich weiß nicht welche I welches die zweite Kammer des Konzertes ist ich habe das alles mal geleert.
Kongress ist eigentlich nur das Haus und Senat also Kongress Senat.
Genau also der Kongress ist sehr nett und Hausaufgabe sind das.
Beides nicht hatte, das bezieht sich nur auf House of Representatives ist nicht so gut gelernt.
Dann weiß ich nicht wie der erste der zweite ist für Zargen houses dann I also das hat auf jeden Fall mehr Power.
Alter Senat ist nicht unwichtig aber wichtiger ist halt the house.
Und da steht ja dann auch umfangreiche Wahlen an dem November und es wird spannend sein zu sehen ob sich in USA noch was retten lässt oder nicht.
Aber auch in im Senat haben die Republikaner halt derzeit die Mehrheit wenn auch nur noch eine einzige Stimme und das heißt es für diese Abstimmung im auch ein paar Republikaner eingeknickt sind sich zumindest enthalten haben.
Drei an der Zahl haben sich enthalten also es gibt 100 Senatoren.
Und 435 representatives und jetzt hast du also die die das geht jetzt halt ins Haus und.
Da haben die Demokraten aber eine sehr starke Unterzahl im House of Representatives und jetzt wäre halt die Frage würde nun.
Das Haus wo sie ohnehin schon eine starke Unterzahl haben das House of Representatives das Ding auch noch bestätigen.
Also den Review act bestätigen oder d.
Diese resolution.
Also dagegen gegen die Änderung der FCC sein.
Also noch mal damit auch du das verstehst.
Ich verstehe sie 50 eine Formulierung war mir nicht ganz klar.
Die Senatoren haben jetzt gesagt hier wir möchten eine Resolution wir haben jetzt verabschiedet und wir berufen uns auf den congressional Review actor congressional Review X eingesetzt der dem Senat.
Der dem Kongress also Senat und house das Recht gibt diese entscheidende FCC zu überstimmen.
Erster Schritt ist getan Senatoren angesagt da wollen wir nicht jetzt muss das noch durchs Haus gehen dass es eine ungleich höhere würde weil im Haus haben die im Moment die Demokraten noch sehr viel weniger.
Person als,
die Republikaner sollte diese Resolution nun durch das Haus gehen dann würde sie am Ende auf dem Tisch von Präsident Donald Trump liegen und der müsste ihr auch noch zustimmen.
Und das spätestens das wird nicht geschehen.
Spätestens das wird nicht geschehen denn die gesamte Nummer mit dieser FCC ist ja auf Geheiß von Donald Trump.
Geschehen und das heißt hier wer letztendlich keinerlei Aussicht auf,
erfolgt aber immerhin eine Dokumentation von Widerstand und einen Eindruck davon wo jeder einzelne Senator Senator in stehen wenn es zu um das Thema der Netzneutralität.
Geht.
Ja seufzt aber gerade meine gute Nachrichten gleich.
So ist das mit den dicken Brettern.
Schlimm schlimm schlimm.
So dann haben wir euch versprochen dass wir euer Berlin Wochenende noch planen.
Genau.
Und was heißt es lädt sich in den Termin alles um das Wochenende um das Wochenende zum LMP 256.
So und wo geht's los wir steigen ein Freitag bevor Logbuch Netzpolitik 256 das ist der 25.Mai 2018 und die erste Gelegenheit,
euch in Berlin zu entspannen bietet sich z.b. bei der Abfrage Abteilung für Redundanz Abteilung 1 rauchfreie Hackerspace.
Und dort gibt es jeden zweiten und vierten Freitag im Monat ab 20 Uhr eine Plattform für Vorträge,
als wir dann an diesem Freitag die Möglichkeit eine Einführung in die funktionale Programmierung mitzunehmen warum nicht wär doch auch schon mal was zu.
Programmierung ist interessant.
Ja Lambda-Kalkül Typ Theorie und so das ist auch für angehende Netzpolitiker durchaus mal ein Thema was man mal erforschen sollte.
Das ganze am Beispiel von Haskell und keine Vorkenntnisse sind von Nöten das ganze findet statt ab 20 Uhr in der Margaretenstraße 30 Nähe.
S und U-Bahnhof Lichtenberg eintritt wie immer frei.
Außerdem am gleichen Abend findet in Berlin mal wieder eine critical mass statt einmassen radfahren durch die Stadt.
Große Freude also oder sind neben so weiß ich nicht regelmäßig so mehrere tausend Leute dran teil und mein Pferd daneben fahrrad Konvoi durch.
Durch Berlin.
In Begleitung von der Polizei die dafür sorgt dass die das tut alles damit in Ordnung verläuft.
Mann lässt sich natürlich jetzt nicht unbedingt durch rote Ampeln und warten der Fahrzeugschlange ablenken.
Und hat also eine lange schöne Strecke durch Berlin mit dem Gesichtern verblüffte genervte und gelangweilter Autofahrer.
Ab und an wetterdaten Aggro.
Haben aber insgesamt ist die Stimmung immer sehr schön es gibt viel Musik dazu schöne bunte Beleuchtung und wenn ihr nicht mit dem Rad nach Berlin kommt in Berlin gibt es gerade eine ganze Reihe Bike sharing Anbieter.
Oh ja oder Ende.
Eisdiele sharing Elsa Carsharing ist einfach nur Verleih Vermietung aber ihr könnt euch da auch so ein kleines fahrrad einfach spontan mieten und mit Gurken.
Jetzt auch Elektrofahrräder.
Mittlerweile auch Elektro Leihfahrräder nicht alles gibt.
Also dass das macht auf jeden Fall Spaß bei schönem Wetter 20 Uhr Heinrichplatz in Kreuzberg geht's los.
Ja und was ihr auf keinen Fall vergessen solltet ist natürlich euer Handtuch denn der 25.Mai ist ja auch der paul.de der Gedenktag an den tollen Autor Douglas Adams.
Autor des Buchs per Anhalter durch die Galaxis und viele andere lustige Schriften und ja.
Ihr wisst ja wer sein Handtuch dabei hat der wird auch von allen anderen sofort jegliche Unterstützung erfahren als Reisender als Anhalter und von daher ist das vielleicht zu.
Empfehlen aber wir müssen nicht unbedingt im Bademantel anzulocken ist fertig Songtext.
Nur dass du auch und später.
Dann doch der letzte Termin am Sonntag nach LMP 256 lädt die Clubkultur Berlin zur antifaschistischen Afterhour,
das geht also ab 12 Uhr los in Berlin Mitte Eisladen hier weiß ich alles was Rang und Namen hat in der Berliner Clubkultur Reclam,
subculture ist für dir der Haupt aufrufende,
die Haupt aufrufen der Institution dass er boutblank ist dabei die Bachstelzen also die Liste ist mir einfach viel zu lang die Hedonistische Internationale ist mit dabei Chaos Computer Club Berlin hat sie auch noch angeschlossen,
rummelsbucht einfach einmal alles ja das SchwuZ das SO36 alles was irgendwie Rang und Namen hat ist beim Aufruf dabei.
Fabrikat Computerclub das wirklich der einzige nicht Musikclub.
Was wieso wir haben auch manchmal Musik.
DSDS nicht unbedingt primär als solcher wahrgenommen wollen wir es mal so sag doch schon die ganze Bäckerei über die Verpflichtung Wissenskluft mit der Geschichte hier aus.
Görlitz.
Und es gibt ein wunderschönes Plakat hier zum Aufruf Dienstag hat sich wirklich wunderbar hauptsache es knallt da drunter eine sind relativ große pinke.
Smarty artige Form die man jetzt auch mit einer Tablette verwechseln könnte.
Auf der Tablette abgedruckt zwei Fahnen oder eingeprägt Zweiflern waren es handelt sich dabei natürlich nur um einen Serviervorschlag.
Navi fahren steht für große Koalition ne.
Große Koalition unter dem Motto keine halben Sachen AFD wegbassen ja und das könnte in große Freude werden weil wenn 1 richtig schönes in Berlin dann ist es.
Bei Sonnenschein draußen zu feiern mit schöner und guter Musik und das glaube ich das wird eine große Freude.
Wir sind progressiv queerfeministisch antirassistisch inclusive Bund und wir haben Einhörner.
Also die lnp Einhorn Standarte darf ich auch gerne anschließen.
Dafür denke ich das könnten große Freude werden und natürlich bekommt ihr dann auch alle, die VV noch euer demogeld.
Anträge gibt's dann vor Ort.
Ja so.
Sein sollen wir also es kursiert gerade das Gerücht dass ihr wie die AFD Wer war das Rheinland-Pfalz oder was den ersten 30 afd-mitglieder in die dort hinfahren irgendwie eine Unterstützung zugesagt hat.
Die Euro auf Tasche.
50 € haben oder nicht haben.
Na da kann man schon mal für demonstrieren.
Der also.
Das nicht irgendwie sogar in USA tatsächlich das an wieso Vögel sich vom weißen Haus irgendwie mit so schildern im Kreis laufen und so was ist auch nur ein Gerücht wahrscheinlich.
Vom weißen Haus doch vom weißen Haus ist immer eine Demo da gibt es irgendwie so ein paar Leute die da immer stehen ja ja aber oder wieso arbeitet sie sind bezahlt oder was.
Real steht da bin ich drin aber ich meine mich mal installieren Vorwurf zu einer.
Ich weiß gerade nicht genau wer diese Leute sind wieder immer vorab Hangover das ist so ähnlich wie hier in Berlin hast du ja auch jeden Tag diese Leute die gegenüber von der chinesischen Botschaft auf der Brücke rumhängen.
Und irgendwas mit Falun Gong oder sowas beklagen.
Ja das ist also diese diese das ist auch so eine Sache eine Demo sollte auch immer noch mal ein Ende finden weil sonst fühlt sie sich einfach dermaßen Stadtbild ein das selbst interessierte Bürger am Ende nichts mehr sagt wer da überhaupt steht,
das ist.
Für mich immer wieder an diese ist das auch die aktuelle Regierungsparteien über lange lange Zeit in Mexiko die Partei die sozusagen über Jahrzehnte immer den Präsidenten gestellt hat die PRI.
Wie steht für übersetzt die Partei der institutionalisierten Revolution.
Eichhörnchen revolutionär muss auch knallen.
Naja oder ein Marsch durch die Institutionen.
Ja so bist du die Montagsdemos irgendwie III irgendwie auch langsam fest gibt's die noch.
Käsealp diese pegida nee das hat das hat sich doch langsam irgendwie das ist.
Du bist wirklich mehr darüber.
Schon soweit sind dass sie ihre Leute damit dafür bezahlen müssen dass sie sich die Blöße geben sich den ganzen Tag irgendwie in Berlin am Hauptbahnhof die Füße im Bauch zu stehen dann glaube ich dann hat das so ein bisschen verloren.
Naja wir schon mal Ende der Veranstaltung.
Genau Übergang in die Planung Vorbereitung für LMP 256.
Genau in unsere neuen bitte Zeitalter nächste.
Übernächste Veranstaltungen Soziales und ilnp 65536.
Stuttgart noch ein bisschen dauern insofern kommt mein lieber nächste Woche dazu und dann sehen wir uns wir freuen uns sehr viele Gesichter dann vielleicht wieder und auch vielleicht das erste Mal zu sehen.
Können uns ein paar lustige Sachen einfallen lassen offene Denkmäler.
Ansonsten hat am Ende die AFD wegbassen Nummer am nächsten am Sonntag wieder raus.
Ilknur schon auf der Bühne klar.
Das wird ein großer Spaß den wir jetzt weiter vorbereiten und.
Du musst mir jetzt hier auf Stopp drücken.
Er wartet noch mal eine E-Mail mit einer aktualisierten Einlasszeit und seid ruhig früh dort das.
40 glaube ich.
Also der Ort der kann man sich ein bisschen aufhalten das ist nicht wie beim letzten Mal dass wir im Prinzip kein Aufenthaltsraum haben sondern wir haben ein ihr nehmt uns am Einlaß und bei der Shirt Ausgaben bisschen Druck raus wenn ihr ein bisschen früher kommt.
Da könnt ihr auch die ganzen anderen des politischen Homies noch treffen Leute wie ihr.
Genau durch hallo wir wollen mit Ihnen über Netzpolitik reden.
Bing.
Bitte danken wir danke ich.
Esther und Wolfgang und eine Person wundert sich jetzt das Paket habe ich noch nicht beim Nachbarn abholen können also Geduld und natürlich auch bei allen anderen die.
Mich irgendwie an darin bestärken mir den ganzen Kram hier weiterhin anzutun es gibt ja auch einige die sich bemühen.
Und dabei der Laune zu halten dafür machen wir das und dafür dass wir euch.
Dazu sind diese Woche bis dann.
Toto.